bonjour thomas
est ce qu'on en sait un peu plus sur
cette manifestation
bonjour magali
oui alors c'est une manifestation qui
était un tube intitulé just is for gil 6
c'est un rassemblement en fait pour
demander à la fin des poursuites pour
les quelques 600 personnes qui sont
poursuivis justement par la justice
américaine pour leur implication dans
les événements au capitole le 6 janvier
dernier alors les organisateurs de cette
manifestation estiment que justement les
participants à la manifestation du 6
janvier dernier était non violent pour
l'immense majorité
d'entre eux alors pour ce samedi 18
septembre jour donc de cette
manifestation à venir il est assez
difficile à d'estimer le nombre de
participants qui pourraient se
rassembler d'une part parce que les
soutiens de donald trump ont pour
certains et pour beaucoup même quitté
les réseaux sociaux et puis aussi parce
que d'autres groupes sont appelés à
rejoindre cet appel à manifester en tout
cas les organisateurs ont demandé
formellement participants de ne pas
porter le moindre signe de ralliement à
l'ancien président donald trump l'idée
c'est vraiment de se consacrer à la
cause de ces personnes qui sont
poursuivis actuellement par la justice
américaine notez enfin que des appels à
contre-manifester circule aussi sur les
réseaux sociaux
merci beaucoup thomas pour pour ces
précisions une manifestation qu'on
suivra de près bien évidemment sur rt
france avec goût thomas bonnin